oh yeah I just remember they we went to
that fishing restaurant I hate that
place so much oh yes oh so there's this
restaurant you can go to in Japan and
it's a very big touristy Place yeah um
there's a few of them in Japan
um yeah where you can fish around fish
right yeah yeah okay so yes you fish you
fish the the fish and then you eat it
right and they'll ask you how you how
you want it prepared but these fish are
like dead so you have to like stab them
with the hook you don't yeah you don't
catch them you kind of have to shimmy
the hook into the part of their body and
then drag them out yeah it's very like
oh this doesn't feel right yeah and it's
like really oh it's gross and also like
they don't even use the fish that you
even fish up right like they have like a
different fish preparedness I don't know
if that's a rumor but I mean I I would
hope so just from seeing how half dead
some of these fish are like I don't know
if I'm I don't know if they're good to
eat like food is mad as well it's all
right it's fine I mean it's it's fine
just it's mid it's just like fine the
sushi was fine it's fine I was just like
damn it it's acceptable I wish I ate
other Sushi like what just anything else
anything else even Sushi though yeah
Sushi chains in Japan even like the 100
yen ones pretty [ __ ] weird they're
pretty decent they do the track as long
as it's not don't get the sushi from the
conveyor belt just order it from the
tablet yeah get it fresh yeah I mean I I
noticed now that it's even if I go to a
conveyor Bel sushi place it's rare that
it's full of sushi anymore most of the
time people just order from the tablets
nowadays yeah yeah and it's because it's
like why would I want the sushi that's
been going around for 40 minutes yeah
yeah Sushi they just made yeah exactly
like that sounds much better I'll do
that thank you yeah even like the
cheapest Sushi change you can find in
Japan is like better than some of the
expensive Sushi though like worldwide so
that's why I in a sense I prefer going
to like cheap convey belt sushis and
some of like the more higher end sushi
places because it's rare that I'm ever
full in like the higher end sushi places
you know yeah yeah but yeah is that what
it is yeah
it's rather than that I'm ever full and
I just feel guilty like ordering more
from the chef to be like you didn't feed
me enough give me more and then you
order like one or two more pieces I'm
like [ __ ] how do I tell oh I don't think
they mind I don't think they might no
they don't mind because they're still
getting the money for yeah
doesn't love everything I mean he you
know he'll eat like the majority of like
the fish and stuff like that but you
know some of the weirder ones like like
he doesn't like not though or like the
sperm sacks or [ __ ] [ __ ] or like I
don't even think he likes uni if I I'm
not too sure but like is he obviously
like but if it's just like oh regular
white fish or or whatever salmon I like
that yeah it's obviously my parents want
to come visit Japan and I'm like damn I
don't know if they're gonna what kind of
sushi I like yeah have you you thought
about this I mean I've had to think
about this actually do you think your
parents are gonna like sushi
um okay so I've not I've thought about
this for both
cutting that like Shinji like yeah
should I take them to I don't know
because you know
um I have my parents coming and then I
also have Sydney's parents coming as
well
um and I'm like uh how can I describe
Sydney's parents like okay so my parents
are very very white British yeah
it's like how do I get them to eat
anything that isn't cooked yeah like
Sydney's parents are like the most
American parents you could like ever
ever imagine like Sydney's dad is like
the epitome of like an American Dad
right
uh he's like I have white and blue yeah
yeah yeah he's like every American Dad
you've seen in every sitcom won every
[ __ ] movie and everything like that
and I'm like how do I I it's it's just
like I I know hi Russell if you're
listening to this by the way it's it's
like I know it's like the type of person
you take to a sushi place and he's
asking where the fork is you know yeah
this is my dad I don't think I've ever
seen my dad use chopsticks maybe he does
I don't know actually yeah can you
pronounce these Chopsticks pretty sure
my mum can this is my day I didn't find
it I'll find out I would I would say
maybe start your parents off on you know
something like salmon right the salmon
yeah I I will see what they like I'll
take them to a sushi yeah and I'll be
like all right we're gonna try one of
everything yeah if you don't like it
don't if you don't like it I'll eat it
I'll eat it and then we'll see how it
goes yeah
yeah I mean I mean I think sushis Sushi
should be fine
um I'm thinking but there are also
people who are like very weird about
eating raw meat right yeah what's it
like I'm gonna be like hey eat this by
the way it's raw horse
I mean see she's not the one I'm worried
about it's some of the other things that
they can find in Japan which might be
having like a little bit harder I think
a sushi is like I want them to try that
and other stuff you can get sushi in
like yeah
Sushi that's good
um and that'll excuse me was fine um
because I don't want to take them to an
omic as a place and then the the sushi
chef has been doing for 50 years like
please enjoy like what the [ __ ] is this
here you go I don't want it here you go
I don't want it seen the I've seen
videos of like someone stabbing the
sushi with the fork and then putting in
like their salad and then eating it yeah
I've seen videos of these from because
of tourist office coming in oh my God
yeah I I wonder why what other dishes do
you want them to try
what is like you know well actually it
depends when are they coming
April I don't know I'll figure it out I
think in January
I just totally [ __ ] maybe like maybe
like a number of some kind
[Music]
although the raw egg might throw them
off a bit yeah I'm gonna make a mean
Sukiyaki I'm gonna be like you gotta
make you gotta make them yeah yeah I I
think I can get away with raw egg you
know I think they'll complain about it
and I think it's weird but as soon as
they try it hopefully hopefully
hopefully I mean I was I feel like the
if you're younger it's really easier
right because you're more open to trying
yeah right obviously if you're older
you've been eating the same things your
whole life and you're like why sure I've
survived without raw egg I don't think I
want to try it it's just like it's the
Japanese Cuisine is just so vastly
different from like Western Cuisine yeah
and you know now the world's become more
let's say like globalized and everything
like that so people our age I think I
feel like we've got we've had more of a
chance to try all these different types
of Cuisines stuff like that yeah but
when you get to a parent's age you know
it's it was it's it was a lot harder to
try different Cuisines back then let's
say in fact it's like surprised me so
much just how much Choice there is now
nowadays UK UK went from like nothing to
like good now exactly you know I go to
like most major cities and they have
like proper Cuisines of like every type
whereas but I remember before you go to
a Chinese restaurant and there was only
like one type of Chinese restaurant you
know which was just basically orange
chicken yeah orange chicken kung pao
chicken like and now like you go to the
UK and there's like so many different
types of Chinese restaurant which is how
it should be it's like Szechuan food
that's like Chinese hot pot
um and I'm just like wow this Choice
wasn't there when I was growing up in
England God knows what the choice was
like when my parents were you know it
might also be because maybe back in our
parents generation there wasn't enough
like uh understanding or knowledge on
the subtle differences of a lot of like
food like that so maybe the maybe they
existed like maybe you know like
Szechuan food and hot pot and like you
know traditional Chinese food did exist
but it was probably all just labeled
under Chinese food yeah right and it's
probably just like oh it's it's from
China so it must be just Chinese food
and then you didn't Pro probably there
wasn't enough information out there to
be like oh this is a different type of
Japanese food yeah well this is a
different type of Indian food yeah well
you know anything like that right it's
like you know I'm sure like back in our
parents day it was just like there's
Asian food and that's it it's Asian food
and there is non-asian I remember when I
was growing up in in Brighton at least
when when we wanted like
when we wanted Chinese or Japanese food
they were both under the same restaurant
yeah it was it wasn't Chinese or
Japanese it was Chinese and Japanese
yeah it was like an Asian Fusion
in terms of like flavors yeah you know
Chinese food is often quite heavy maybe
oily yeah whereas Japanese food it's
very light not so many spices
meanwhile Korean food is full of spices
right I mean I remember I remember when
it's growing well I remember when
growing up Korean food just wasn't a
thing no no no I was like you you had
zero choice of Korean cuisine and nobody
knew about it either it was either
Chinese or Japanese
you know yeah and it's just weird now
seeing how many different Cuisines are
like coming up there like Vietnamese
cuisine is like coming up as well
whereas before I was just like oh I
guess I I I've had Thai food that's you
know that's that's just all the stuff
before it was like let's get up that
Asian restaurant that has Sushi Pad Thai
yeah
so that's everything I could be wrong
but I'm pretty sure didn't the Thai
government and I think it might still
does like they they sponsor a lot of
people opening up Thai restaurants
abroad
um if they do that's five hit because
they wanted Thai food to be like really
well known right yeah
um I'm pretty sure they did that okay I
wouldn't be surprised because I think if
you look at all the foreign foods from
like southeast Asia like it's only like
Thai food is the big one like it's been
pushed the most yeah I think it's
because the government was like hey we
need to get our food out there I mean it
makes sense when pretty much everyone in
my parents and dad's side who emigrated
out of Thailand started a restaurant
business so yeah I'm pretty sure there's
like a text out I guess there's
something some kind of program maybe
there is not a single Thai person who
has come out from outside Thailand who
didn't at one point in analyze yeah I'm
just I'm just thinking I'm just like
we're gonna fact checking okay all right
what do you think 2002
oh 2002. yeah thousands of restaurants
of the world to make them authentic oh
wow okay yeah so that's my head yeah
because that because they realize like
Hey how do we get our name on the map
let's make bomb ass food the people are
gonna be like no I want Chinese food
yeah yeah and you think about it more
right you know of the country you know
about it like yeah I don't know a lot
about some other Southeast Asian
countries because the food isn't really
like pushed that's true yeah and it's
kind of it's very neat and food is very
intrinsically linked to the culture too
like dude I mean I swear half of the
hype around Italy is how God damn good
their food is yeah you know but no one
ever thinks to stop about their
government we don't talk about the
Italian government the Italian politics
Italian politics are kind of whack but
their food you know you think about it
yeah everyone every single family member
that has emigrated out of Thailand uh
and I haven't started a [ __ ] big
family by the way or in my parents
generation started a restaurant business